we have a news of yet another one of
these tragic accidents the daily beast
is reporting that another vladimir putin
ally
has been found dead after quote
suffocating
on a business trip
from a quote
stroke
hmm
another top ally reports the daily beast
of russian president vladimir putin has
died this week
this time of an alleged stroke while on
a business trip in the village of
roschino in russia's far east region
vladimir sungorkin 68 years old was
editor-in-chief of the russian state
newspaper according to the newspaper syn
gorkhan died suddenly after showing
signs of suffocation during the trip the
all of these terms are in quotes even in
the article by the way
quote it happened absolutely suddenly
nothing foreshadowed we were in the
village of rostino we were driving we
were already making our way towards
kabarovsk we planned to get there in the
evening and from there to moscow all was
good said his colleague who accompanied
him on the business trip
according to zakharov sangorikan fell
unconscious minutes after suggesting
their group find a beautiful place for
lunch three minutes later vladimir began
to suffocate we took him out for fresh
air he was unconscious nothing helped
the doctor who did the initial exam said
apparently it was a stroke but this is
only the initial conclusion uh now some
of you may be confused wait why why did
a putin ally die i thought it was putin
antagonists and putin enemies who kept
accidentally dying remember two weeks
ago i told you about the guy who these
are just tragic accidents he was in the
hospital for treatment for a serious
illness and he just fell out the window
at the hospital very very tragic
accident now that was an antagonist of
putin so here's what you have to
understand there's a bit of both going
on
the the way that this is believed to
function is
the putin antagonists are sometimes
killed
but also putin allies
that are suspected of jumping ship or
are suspected of moving in a disloyal
way
they also sometimes have to be taken out
and wikipedia actually maintains an
article
called 2022
russian businessman mystery deaths
and you can just look through this and
see the list and it is wild wild wild
wild and the list is quite long
um you might remember reveal maganov
he's the guy i told you about who was
reportedly hospitalized for heart
problems and depression
and then quote fell out of a window
and was a big um
putin critic
so
as we've talked about before
many of you when we do these stories
will react and say david this stuff is
so obvious like no one believes that
these are accidents or deaths from
illness
why isn't putin slicker in how he does
it that's exactly the point
as i've told you before the whole point
here is
it's important that it be known that
these stupid explanations
are just untrue stupid explanations
that's the idea that's how you sow fear
if it was really believed that this was
a stroke and the other guy fell out the
window or whatever
um then it wouldn't have the chilling
effect that it's meant to have and so
we're going to continue tracking these
it's about i believe uh 20 or 22 various
oligarchs allies and antagonists who
have died in just tragic accidents
supposedly is what we're supposed to
believe um we're going to continue
following that list and you can check
out that list on the wiki page which we
will link to